nouvel épisode de la série dans son
corps aujourd'hui je reçois clémence du
groupe charlotte et comme d'habitude
elle vient nous parler de sa
particularité physique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
clémence est ingénieur du son et
musicienne elle et bassiste du groupe
charlotte du métal roland duss
électro punk pas vouloir écouter
salut clémence alors quelle est la
particularité à toi ma particularité
c'est que je suis ni ferme intersexe tu
définis comme une femme tout à fait
intersexe donc intersexe c'est à dire
que c'est je suis une femme mais qui
n'est pas dans les standards qu'on
attend en général des femmes une
personne intersexe est une personne dont
les caractéristiques sexuelles
biologique ne correspondent pas à la
norme binaire masculin féminin est ce
que tu te souviens justement le jour où
tu as tu découvert l'existence de
l'intersexuation commente a accueilli sa
aa oui je me souviens très bien j'avais
vu un reportage sur arte qui s'appelle
entre deux sexes on y voit le quotidien
de deux personnes intersexe et je me
suis dit ah ah bah oui en fait ce truc
qu'on n'arrivait pas à expliquer
concrètement c'est une fille mais bon
pas tout à fait mais il faut que tu faut
que tu ailles d'un côté de l'autre et
aux taches me suis dit ouais ils sont
comme moi je suis comme eux et tout va
bien moi j'avais quand j'avais 18 ans
l'intersexuation elle se manifeste de
façon différente d'une personne à
l'autre et elle peut évoluer au moment
de la puberté par exemple avec la
modification de la musculature et
l'apparition des poils et de la baronne
et c'est
que ces spas c'est pas un truc que tu as
ça a été un genre soulagement de dire ah
ouais mais en fait à un nom et il ya
plein de gens parce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui sont qui sont qu'ils ont de moi
aussi parce que quand tu as grandi
en tant qu on disant voilà tu es malade
il faut de soigner une fille fait pas
comme ça
tu vas tu attires inc les cancers des
ovaires et où c'est à dire en fait non
il ya des gens qui sont comme ça aussi
qui vivent très bien comme ça
qu'ils ont subi aussi des choses que moi
j'ai refusé
en prenant enfin dans ma tête je prenais
des risques en fait tu vois mais
en fait il n'avait pas vraiment plus
c'était plus pour pour se conformer à ce
qu'on attendait de moi on ne sait pas
qui c'est une espèce d'entité m palpable
parce qu'en fait enfin que ce soit mais
mes proches ou autres on s'en fout quoi
il ya ce truc de
[Musique]
vouloir faire rentrer dans une case on
alors que toi de tes à cheval sur deux
cases je sais pas trop mais c'est ok ça
comme ça bastia ma famille ils ont ils
ont toujours respecté mes choix mais
c'était j'ai grandi à la campagne il n'y
avait pas internet il n'est pas donc un
accès à l'information qui était très
limité donc quand tu as des des médecins
qui te tais par
tata gamine les médecins me disent oh là
elle est malade parce qu'elle est poilu
il faut la soigner bon tu veux la
soigner par la ccl train dit que c'est
plus dans ce sens là qu aussi longtemps
sûrement souffert quelque part parce qu'
ils demandaient que ça que je puisse
être bien dans ma peau que je puisse
être en bonne santé et épanouie quoi
j'ai souvent des personnes qui disent
ouais mais pourquoi tu as besoin de te
mettre dans une case de dire que que tu
es lesbienne que que tu es intersexe
machin alors qu après tout tu tu met en
avant que côté comme tout le monde que
c'est qu'en fait c'est pas une case c
c'est une définition interne est en fait
les choses si on peut pas les nommer
elle n'existe pas en fait si tu veux
c'est à pas ce moment là pour dire je
suis une femme intersexe ça veut dire
que je suis une femme comme on imagine
dans les standards et vu que je le suis
pas et vu que je suis pas un homme non
plus bas je n'existe pas donc il faut un
mot pour nommer les choses et c'est pas
du tout se restreindre la chose que non
que le nommé être intersexe c'est pas
une orientation sexuelle c'est juste le
fait d'avoir des caractéristiques
physiques considéré comme mal et
d'autres considérés comme femelles
tu vois par exemple dans l'orientation
sexuelle c'est souvent assez souvent des
hétéros qui me font remarquer qu'il faut
remarquer cela pour quoi pourquoi dire
voilà je suis tsb nt gaieté parce que
imagine toi si tu étais rouge quoi je ne
te les taureaux alors que pas du tout et
que tous les jours qui te ferait draguer
par des mecs super lourd tu as envie de
leur dire écoutez les gars je suis pas
intéressé je suis hétéro et le fait de
dire ce mot eh ben c'est compris par
l'autre et dire ok ça veut dire qu'il
n'est pas intéressé ça veut dire qu'ils
aiment les femmes ça veut dire que je
vais arrêter d'être lourd avec lui donc
nominé pas se restreindre ouais c'est ça
parce que tu sais ce que tu dis là en
plus c'est des choses qui te définis ci
mais qui se définissent pas
exclusivement on ta personnalité et se
limite pas à
femmes intersexe lesbiennes des
caractéristiques mais comme je veux l'on
bat things in seaway ses papattes accent
j'ai d'autres défauts je te
la coque duquel bassiste et
du coup de toi même je pense notamment à
la période de l'adolescence est ce qu'il
ya un moment où tu as été tentées de
masquer un peu
le fait que tu aies intersexe je sais
pas que ce soit au niveau de la barbe ou
deux tons rapport à la féminité est ce
qu'il ya eu un moment où au total air de
l'assumer maintenant est-ce que ça le
soit été le cas non bien non pas parce
que tu as une pression constante
ha ha ha ha ha de confort mais justement
à ce qu'on attend plus ou moins de toi
c'est capté une femme donc quand même
les puits à aller aussi voilà il ya un
côté un peu de temps envie de séduire un
petit peu convaincante à d'autres
cherchent un peu tu veux tu en voilà
donc ils vont acheter une fille j'essaie
de me maquiller tout mais c'est ce que
je renvoie à ce que parce que je
renvoyais me plaisait pas du tout et
puis elles ont un toit sert les femmes à
barbe c'est le cirque c'est la maladie
ont du coup la maladie de peau nue voilà
mais j'en rigole qui va mais mais mais
voilà et du coup bas le on m'a fait
faire du laser définitif que j'ai
accepté de poids pour la barbe violation
de la loi et pas complètement non non
non il en reste assez pour que ça
ressemble un peu à quelque chose mais
j'ai perdu quand même là que ce qui me
limite je peux pas tuer cg des poils qui
est qu'ils sont un peu la voix qui sont
là mais elle pas entre eux et donc ça
c'est une reste donc ça a bien marché
pas de souci mais c'est c'est un laser
tu veux c'est un peu comme le passé un
peu comme la clique mentation et à tous
c'est à dire que c'est voilà le laser il
y suit ton au fond musculeux et le
détruit donc ça au niveau de la
sensation c'est un peu comme si tu
t'amuses à faire des petits coups de
taser comme ça donc c'est très
désagréable c'est très humiliant ça
brûle et tu t'es dit après coup tu dis
mais comment j'ai pu accepter ça
je regrette aujourd'hui awa de vêtements
nicheurs parce que parce que c'est une
forme de mutilation quoi clairement
c'est pas une mutilation aussi aussi
élevé que
2 que les mutilations je suis d'autres
intersexe par rapport à
mai mais c'en est quand même
donc à sa puis il ya aussi le côté quand
ça repousse à repousser je les fais
qu'une fois le laser moment c'était en
plusieurs fois sans qu'il m'en reste
encore un peu c'est qu'après j'ai
réfléchi j'ai fait j'y vais par quoi tu
es heureusement ma famille n'ont pas
forcé à y aller et donc c'était fond de
teint c'est pour cacher un peu et tout
mais tout le monde le voyez quoi
il ya des moyens comme les hormones ou
la chirurgie pour modifier les
caractéristiques sexuelles des personnes
intersexe et sont souvent employés dans
l'enfance c'est à dire sans le
consentement de la personne concernée
donc en fait du coup ça fait que tu toi
même tu sais pas où tu en es tu dégage
quelque chose que qui fait que tu as
l'air paumé et pas parce que tu es beau
mais parce que c'est les autres qui de
pommes
c'est mais je veux pas dire voilà c'est
le grand méchant monde pas du tout mais
les hommes ont de la barbe j'ai de la
barbe ça veut pas dire que je suis un
homme c'est comme ma grand mère à de la
moustache célèbre ça que ma grand-mère
est un homme bon dos un jour je me suis
dit man peut-être que si je passe qu'on
appelait toujours les gens ils hésitent
et monsieur madame était toujours un
malaise comme ça en étant pas barbu au
ces jeunes genre un peu baggy et où je
me suis dit tiens je vais mettre une
jupe et puis là quand même on va quand
même appelé madame est en fait tu as d
une jupe à carreaux et du coup on fait
tout le monde croyait que c'était un kit
dupont n'avait jamais autant appeler
monsieur koala dont 15 degrés jours pour
ça que le pays ait connu
du coup les gens ont pensé que j'étais
un mec avec un kit quoi donc c'est
complètement raté quoi
alors question c'est est celle où mais
c'est un secret pour personne que dans
notre société c'est quand même plus
facile d'être un mec en rond que des
screen dadaab est ce que tu as
l'impression qu'il ya des fois où ça et
des
peut-être d'être genre et au masculin
sera en tout cas de penser appel dans
ton boulot tout le temps voileux
en fait moi là-bas bison moi même elle
dépend de ce que les gens voient ouais
tu vois donc un coup sûr en particulier
maintenant où on a tout le temps le
masque ce qui fait que du coup ça doit
pas forcément que j'ai de la barbe et
comme j'ai un regard assez féminine j'ai
les cheveux longs
il ya
ça revient son côté dans la rue ça peut
être un coup l'autre selon selon le le
point de vue de l'individu ben ben
typiquement
la demoiselle beaux cheveux nanani
nanana ça m'avait pas manquer voilà et
ce n'est pas ce sentiment d'insécurité
parce que je lance tu vois mais
j'imagine que une fille qui a pas mon
physique c'est clairement si flippant et
c'est quelque chose que les hommes
les hommes 6 nous ne se rendent pas
compte qu'ils se rendent pas compte que
ce soit d'une fête de ne pas le subir
mais se rendent pas compte aussi parce
que forcément bas il y en a qui se font
ça et en plus je suis sûr qu'il part
d'une bonne intention qui veulent
complimenter maintenant arrêtez les gars
vous faites juste peur
voilà le 15e la suite ben oui voilà
un boulot à wayne dans le boulot basse
et on dit dans la musique s'est ouvert
c'est oui bien sûr mais c'est quand même
des métiers qui sont qui sont assez
poilus si je peux me permettre
voilà c'est la vie de tournée l'avis de
l'avis de tournage machin s'est passé
sur un milieu d'hommes donc comme je
suis technicienne 1 g 100 g débuté plus
jeune j'ai carrément vu que le l'accueil
qui m'a été réservé était complètement
différent simon mon intermédiaire me
voyait comme une meuf vous voyez comme
quand même quoi il ya un côté quand ils
voient comme un maître bombasse et hop
tu connais le job vas-y quand c'est
comme une meuf ceara ça va aller un
machin tu sais tu en fait il ya comprend
le bruit enfants quoi quelque part ça je
ressens vraiment les musiciennes aussi
comment ça ça quand ça se passe dans le
milieu de la musique comme on commentait
accueille alors
ça se passe alors mieux que dans des
milieux plus plus traditionnelle plus
conservateurs je pense que dans la
musique c'est plus facile d'être
intersexe que d'être un excellent
d'avoir dans l'armée par exemple je
pense mais globalement il ya quand même
il ya quand même une pression de genre
mais plus
comment dire
on attend des fiches sur scène que
soient certaines choses je me rappelle
donc tu vois par exemple dans mon groupe
au début on n'avait pas de bassiste et
et donc il voulait à 6 quoi voilà et il
ya un ami à eux qui arrive il ya
toujours des aura toujours des amis qui
ont des idées je vous en remercie parce
que des fois elles sont super bonne les
idées des fois elles sont super
mauvaises et surtout selon elles sont
mauvaises drôle
donc ça là c'était ouais en fait dans
ton groupe faudrait trop que tu es une
fille kouame jarre garage habite quoi
béchard que tout n'est ce pas lui de
suer tous et donc les gars quand ils
m'ont recruté on y voit là ça y est on a
la fille est au garage et au jeu voyage
mais pas à pas la bassiste sexy clichés
qu'on attend qu'on attend d'une maison à
cannes bat danger létal houphouet et
puis tu veux dans les
les groupes de métal féminin
souvent ça tourne autour du physique de
la chanteuse du physique de la bassiste
alors que étonnamment les gars et non
pas autour du physique du chanteur ou
arrêter ça franchement c'est beaucoup si
la fille elle est musicienne vous parlez
de la musique s'il gagne les musiciens
ont parlé de la musique quoi voilà c'est
donc donc il ya quand même ce poêle et
ce poids là mais moins et puis il ya
plein d'événements dans la seine qui
font que que maintenant le sexisme
beaucoup plus combattu le racisme aussi
donc ça c'est une très bonne chose du
coup j'ai la chance d'être dans un
groupe où
dès le début ça a été voilà
r il ya des personnages il faut que le
personnage se soit une extension de plus
ou moins de toi-même et et avec
justement la personnalité que tu as
c'est un terrain
c'est un terrain génial donc ça fait
déjà à un personnage
comment dire scéniquement
fort mais en plus parce que ça c'est un
univers imaginaire qu'on a quand astique
futuriste
et ça permet de relier cet univers
futuriste à la réalité mais quelque part
tous les trucs science fiction c'est ça
c'était que tu devrais recevoir survient
machin n'importe quel truc de science
fiction ça a relié à des choses là de la
vraie vie et du coup ça fait 1 pour moi
un tremplin
absolument conduire super efficace quoi
c'est à dire c'était un peu plus la
musique du groupe culte se renseigne sur
un peu sur ce qu'on est tu vas savoir
que je suis intersexe tu vas tu as
acheté être intersexe et ça libère la
parole donc j'en franchement je suis
super contente d'être content d'être
tombé sur des gars qui sont assurées
assez à cheval
sur la transmission de
ces sujets la cua et la bienveillance
qui va avec micha et dans l'est dans
l'ue dans la série des réactions celle
où des gens c'est quoi les les questions
on pose le plus souvent
le plus souvent
dans les questions celle au seul ou par
action et les gens ont généralement peu
de filtres ouais quand quand ils se
trouvent face à une personne qui est
différente de ce qu'ils ont l'habitude
de des gens qui ont l'habitude de
rencontrer et des fois ils sont un peu
on va de je te pose la première question
qui me vient alors déjà il faut qu'ils
comprennent ce que je suis est-ce que ça
c'est déjà pas évident parce que en
général
il y en a 40 sont un petit peu éduqués
qui voit que j'ai un regard de féminin
et qui pensent que je suis trans et
encore j'explique un peu ils pensent que
je suis en transition mais quand je dis
que je suis pas en transition il demande
why comment comment une fois il ya un
mec qui était
utilisé par les qui me kim genre et au
masculin et et du coup je lui ai
expliqué en revanche chez les femmes
battues et il était un petit peu
alcoolisé et
et je pense que ça résume très bien ce
que les des gens comme ça peuvent
ressentir il m'a fait comment femmes
savent très peu de mots voilà après il y
avait de la détresse dans le regard
quatuor donc donc c'est vraiment ça
tourne autour de ça c'est comment
pourquoi et surtout le plus important
quand il parle à quelqu'un que tu ne
connais pas mais qu'est ce que tu as
dans ton pantalon c'est vraiment la base
je veux dire comment on peut dialoguer
toi et moi si je sais pas s'il y en a un
là tu vois et c'est vraiment ça
déstabilise les gens alors que
normalement le le sexe est censé être un
tabou ce à raison et bien tu tues tu
montres pas tes parties génitales pour
présenter à quelqu'un ça pour commander
finalement c'est ce qui nous semble voit
la ccva sait pas très bien vu d'un point
de vue pénal à raison par contre si on
ne peut pas te définir en sachant s'il
ya donnant ses morts ouais c'est ça
quand tu y penses absurde mais c'est une
réalité donc il faut que les gens c'est
c'est si convient maintenant je me rends
compte que c'est plus facile de
communiquer avec des gens qui croient
que je suis un gars technique ou une
genre masculin c'est fluide c'est et si
j'ai envie de dire sachant que le
le feeling passe bien je dois lâcher une
femme barbu basta que d'avoir quelqu'un
qui sent quelque chose d qui est pas
claire et qui va patiner à un bonjour
qu'est ce que souvent tu va tenter face
à une grande présentation quoi
donc il va essayer de
trouver des indices pour savoir ce que
tu as dans le froc pour savoir comment
il doit de parler j'imagine que des des
questions comme ça tu veux en avoir tout
le temps
sans trahir un secret on est allé aux
toilettes avant de l'annoncer cette
émission était à l'aise c'est une très
bonne chance d aller voter allez dans
les toilettes des dégâts et tu me disais
que ça t'évite d'avoir à prendre la tête
à chaque fois expliqué à darwin on met
en fête est sûr c'est que c'est c'est en
société quant à moi ce que quand je suis
chez moi je me dis pas tiens je suis une
meuf barbu suis pas une vraie femme et
je suis nara de la nature pas comme chez
moi tout va bien quand je suis à
l'extérieur je dois m'habituer à aux
conventions
qui sont faites pour une majorité certes
mais comment dire c'est un poids qui est
là pour tout le monde en fait les
personnes qui sont pas intersexe qui
sont pas le subissent aussi je veux dire
quand on dit voilà tu es une femme le
les poids qu'ont les femmes a subi en
tant que femme j'ai les mêmes c'est
juste que pour moi ça touche à mon
intégrité physique donc tout donc je les
refuse mais quand quand tu étais une
fille qui est qui et stands en stands
combien qui est à peu près normalement
constitué comme
et que qui a juste un petit peu de
graisse ou qui a juste un petit peu le
subit ça aussi donc donc mais elle va se
plier parce que ça ça comment dire ça ça
ne remet pas en question son identité
profonde mais malgré tout c'est ça c'est
super oppressant et ça n'a pas de sens
qu'elle lequel le subit et donc pour les
toilettes en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que si je vais dans les toilettes des
femmes elles me disent bah c'est pas ici
les toilettes des hommes et je peux les
comprendre parce que je ressemble à un
mec quoi est en général bien je prends
comment dire quand j allais encore je
disais bah en fait je suis une femme et
elle le prenais toujours bien c'est à
dire qu'elle avait juste peur d'avoir
des mecs qui viennent les remous créés
dans les toilettes donc le point de vue
je le comprends mais je peux pas vivre
tout le temps en le justifiant de ce que
je suis et
et quelque part c'est un truc que je
pense personne ne veut même ces filles
là qui me font remarquer ça je pense que
si elle était si elle était au courant
de
que des personnes comme ça existe il y
aurait plus malaise
en vérité j'adore aller dans les
toilettes des mac parce que j'adore
redit qu'il était lui même
est en fait c'est vrai c'est un peu
c'était un peu mon idée c'est pas de
regarder la télé
était c'était jeu j'imagine que ça doit
être usant à force d'être toujours en
train
d'expliquer qui on est et de répondre à
des questions et 2 du coup
il ya deux questions que je me pose la
première c'est toi
aux gens quittent
on rencontrait pour la première fois
qu'est ce que tu aurais envie de leur
dire c'est quoi la latitude que tu as
envie qu'ils aient avec toi tu te sens
tu à l'aise sans suspense oui c'est
super plaisant et j'ai des problèmes de
dépression et d'anxiété c'est alors il
ya beaucoup de facteurs je vais pas dire
c'est parce que j'ai une pression
sociale que j'ai des problèmes de
dépression et d'anxiété c'est ça un
facteur
comment dire plutôt global mais le
problème fondamental c'est que pour mme
fan j'ai compris ça genre cette année tu
vois 29 pichot c'est que quand toute ta
vie on dit est pas normal tu es malade
tu vas avoir un cancer des ovaires tu
vas être stérile les filles elles sont
pas comme toi mais les garçons non plus
et qu'il ya que les garçons et les
filles donc toi tu n'existes pas
alors que ton corps il est parfaitement
fonctionnel en fait tu ne sais
absolument pas te dose et donc la
moindre douleur la moindre sensation un
peu étrange la moindre pensée qui sort
du cadre que tu t'es que tu que tu t'es
construit pour se stabiliser c'est la
crise d'angoissé et c'est normal parce
que tu attaques un baromètre
interne donc ça c'est voilà donc ça
c'est quelque chose quand même de deux
je pense qui est quand même assez assez
lourd et les problèmes que j'avais des
problèmes de poids aussi donc en plus
je faisais plus de 100 kilos et j'ai
comme moi j'ai perdu plus de 20 kilos en
un an mais parce que aussi j'ai fait
j'ai une démarche le poissard cellier un
de façon à tourner état mental et tout
ça mais du coup tu as une déconnexion de
ton corps comme ça est un rapport à la à
l'affect et à thé dans la peur fait tu
es dans la peur de toi parce que on est
contre on voit je pense oui et
maintenant que je me sens à l'aise que
avec mon corps et que je sens que les
gens aussi sont à l'aise avec mon corps
ce bizarre c'est que des chances quant à
l'aise avec avec avec moi - en tant
qu'individu et en tant que de ce que je
représente battre le corps il a fondu
c'est normal bon j'ai couru aussi
beaucoup et du vélo mais
comment tu aimerais que les gens qui
doit pour la première fois à se
comporter avec toi bats comme avec tout
le monde ouais je veux manger déjà comme
il aimerait qu'on se comporter avec eux
ils y voient là il y en a plein qui juge
en disant voilà c'est pas normal
à discuter machin tu devrais le cacher
tout mais en fait si tu regardes bien
tous les gens se discute un peu comme
chez un peu différente les gens se
confient beaucoup à moi ils disent comme
elle elle est bizarre elle est barbu je
vais pouvoir tout lui dire tu as un côté
un peu confessionnal comme ça et j'aime
bien moi ça permet de 6,2 me fait rêver
de faire évoluer mais mes propres
réflexions et tout est est en fait je me
rends compte que tout le monde a quelque
chose de différent pas forcément visible
et en fait et en fait tu te rends compte
que le standard il faut pour qu'ils
lâchent et bord en fait il tout le monde
là là là intériorisé ce standard tout le
monde se le fait subir et le fait subir
aux autres alors qu'en fait on a tous
quelque chose de différent alors que le
personnel donc finalement bah ouais
c'est encore là bien sûr tu vois
enfin rentrer dans l'intimité des gens
et ea pourrait du coup en sens inverse
on peut dire que toutes les différences
en forme de standards aussi dans ce qui
est de la limite de l'acceptable
évidemment de du respect de soi et des
autres donc je dirais j'ai envie que les
gens se comporte avec moi comme il
aimerait qu'on se comporte avec eux tout
bêtement voilà sauf s'ils sont super
chevaux sauf si ça traite mal eux-mêmes
voilà exactement là non à 90 ha non
c'est pas la première fois que tu viens
parler du fait d'être un père sexe âge
et a déjà donné d'autres d'autres
interviews le fait que tu sois aussi une
personnalité publique est ce que
tu ressens un peu peut-être comme un
poids ou comme une mission je ne sais
pas le fait d'être quelque part porte
parole porte drapeau des personnes car
c'est que c'est déjà est ce que tu te
considères comme comme tel j'ai pris le
choix d'assumer mon
on intersexualité à sion pasteur
sexuation ou le fait d'être une femme va
remuer est en quête toi voilà exactement
ben oui complètement
assez tard vers v 24 ans j'ai décidé
mais je me dis allez j'arrête les
conneries j'arrête de masques et je
laisse tomber le fond de teint je laisse
pousser la barbe on va voir ce que ça
donne hélas pour la première fois de ma
vie je me suis reconnue et en fait je me
suis dit mince
en fait j'ai tout ce temps là je peux
jette rejeté pas moi mais là c'est cool
chez moi on verra bien et je savais à ce
moment là que
j'allais devoir l'expliquer et que
c'était c'était ouest et munitions de
l'expliquer je peux pas laisser tu peux
pas imposer quelque chose de de
déstabilisant pour les gens et leur dire
vous êtes des connards parce que vous
savez pas ce que c'est moi même j'ai pas
su ce que c'était avant 18 ans je peux
pas en vouloir aux autres ne pas savoir
ce que c'est ce jean veut globalement
peut-être aux médias qui pourrait mettre
un peu moins en avant certains profils
et peut-être plus d'autres donc du coup
je savais que que j'allais devoir que
j'allais devoir faire ça et que les gars
chaque fois qu'on allait m'en parler je
pouvais pas
juste faire une blague et partir quoi et
qui sont bas après bien sûr je vais pas
arriver là bonjour vous connaissez
l'intersection je suis pas je suis pas
témoin d un père avec en même temps la
com com au delà au delà des rencontres
ici voici un passionné curieuse si je
sens qu'il ya une ouverture par rapport
à ça bah je vais évidemment je vais en
parler je vais être à l'écouté puis et
puis voilà après si je sens qu'il ya
parce qu'évidemment tout n'est pas tout
n'est pas beau tout n'est pas rose
il ya des gens clairement kippour qui
pensent que que que je devrais pas
existé quoi on en adhérant à dire ce qui
est j'ai jusqu'au bout comme ça y est
j'ai fait pas mal d'interviews avant
dont une balle à la première avec une
interview à france tv slash qui était
d'ailleurs un média public et juin que
je remercie de tout coeur parce que ça
montre aussi qu'il ya une envie vraiment
de faire connaître ces sujets là
et qui a été très bien très bien fait et
très bien accueilli j'ai pu voir en fait
les réactions des gens à faire un violon
souvient profité pour faire un petit peu
une petite étude sociale
g et ce qui est ressorti de ça c'est que
en fait les surtout pour les femmes
c'était un côté libérateur du style ah
ben oui si elle se permet ça moi je vais
peut-être arrêter d'enlever trois poils
que j'ai entre les sourcils parce que
sinon bah je suis mal vu au boulot si
j'ai trois poils elle elle sent bien
dans sa peau
beaucoup plus ce genre de choses donc ça
ça m'a vraiment fait super chaud au
coeur ce que je fais en fait c'est utile
de vous dévoiler comme ça a contrario il
y avait j'avais passé des choses du
style bon il ya les blagues nulles inter
interco intermarché hyper sport et il y
avait
je ne suis pas un homme monsieur c'est
le
nom binaire d'ailleurs je me rappelle
plus du nom de la personne en question
mais c'est un non sujet mais bon
certains trucs cessé d'en laisser une
blague qui revient souvent chez les gens
moi j'aimerais être un hélicoptère de
combat ça c'est un truc sur un
bon voilà comme personne enfin s'il
avait écouté l'interview en question
soit et avec ses potes sont donc bon
voilà mes blagues pas drôles de la
plaque au web et j'en fais des blagues
pas drôles à côté de la plaque voilà
donc donc je leur en veux pas mais mais
du coup elle atteint tout ça pour dire
que oui donc assez et des choses
beaucoup plus graves du style un petit
coup chez le véto la piquouse ou alors à
un calibre n'affronterait deux omoplates
je faisais des choses passées comme ça
donc je sais que il ya une haine une
haine qui vient de je ne sais pas quoi
parce qu'en vérité ma couple demeure
bloqué ma coupe de barbe est là pas plus
d'impact sur la vie des gens que la
coupe de cheveux les autres nan impact
sur la mienne non voilà mais il ya sept
il ya cette violence là quand même hein
donc donc je m'ouvre et je suis
pédagogique que si je sens qu'il ya
qu'il ya une une réceptivité quoi de la
part d'individus pour tout ce qui est
des pressions tout ça il ya aussi le
côté des fois tu te lèves et tu te dis
je n'aurai pas la force je leur ai juste
pas la force de sortir et de devoir me
confronter à ça parce que parce que je
suis quelqu'un d'assez sensible et que
et que c'est pas toujours facile de
deux d'écouté
d'écouté de se dévoiler parler des
choses intimes même en gardant une
distance quand les gens hier plus il ya
des gens qui sont très bienveillant mais
qui convient c'est quand même lourd par
exemple arrêter quelqu'un qui me dit
voilà
moi je n'aurais jamais le courage d'être
d'être comme tu es comment tu fais
comment je fais quoi je peux les gars je
suis tu vois que jarre
ça ça te rappelle que c'est presque un
monstre et que c'est cool que quelque
part tu puisses pas avant une courage de
te suicider quoi on sait que c'est pas
du tout ça qui va le dire c'est
bienveillant mais horriblement maladroit
ouais c'est très fort ses essais et ses
traits réguliers alors si un jour vous
avez envie de me dire tu es super
courageuse et où allez-y quelque part
c'est agréable mais jusque quand c'est
un tout comme ça il ya des fois tu te
dis demain je vais pas réussir à me
lever vrai voilà et bomba au final tu y
arrives et et je pense pour si vous vous
dites
je n'aurai pas le courage si si vous
l'avez prenez le il est juste là le
courage que ce soit si vous n'êtes pas
être pas parce que vous êtes un terme ce
que je voulais être part sinon sa mère
mais vous avez forcément quelque chose
de différent et une difficile dans votre
vie vous n'êtes pas forcément envie de
me montrer aux autres mais mais ce n'est
il faut y aller quoi et tu penses que le
fait justement de être exprimée
publiquement peut être exposé
donc quand une fois au delà au delà du
fait d'avoir deux peut être exposé à ces
réactions y perdurent des gens qui
commentent et c'est ce que je pense que
ça t'a rajouter un poids de
je représente une
je représente pas seulement juste qui je
suis mais je représente aussi les
personnes intersexe ou est ce que ça t'a
un peu
boosté en terminant ça m'a plus libéré
dans le sens que de 2
de toutes les réactions que j'ai eue a
déjà le fait de dire voilà la base
l'interview de france qui vit c'était un
média où il n'y avait pas des millions
de vues c'était je ne serai pas de
quantifier parce que c'est pas mon
délire de regarder les stats fait choix
mais je voyais qu'il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de commentaires donc je me suis
dit moi je vais ça va me servir de
support peut-être dès fois pour envoyer
à certaines personnes pour expliquer ce
que je suis machin mais pour moi ça
allait rester en fait dans un cadre
intime pour ça que j'ai aussi que j'ai
parlé de mon intimité de manière de
manière libérée tu vois et et au final
ça fait des millions de vues j'ai eu des
gens qui ont écrit le côte d'ivoire du
canada du vietnam et au et a donc encore
gros ben voilà super le monde entier
connais mes parties génitales
et bambins y en a d'autres pour qui
c'est le cas mais on fait pas le même
métier
et du coup ça m'a enlevé le poids de me
dire
comment dire de quelque part d'avoir la
chance de
vivre ce que les personnes 6 on pas
inter jardiner d'une femme qui se sent
femme qui est née avec les organes à un
homme qui soit 100 hommes c'est à dire
que que les gens eh ben ils savent ce
que je suis quand il me parle tu vois
teinte imagine toi si tu avais si à
chaque fois que tu devais parler
discuter avec quelqu'un qui te dis mais
ce qu'il le voit que je suis un mec est
ce que est ce que et et qu'au bout de
une heure de discussion tu te rends
compte qu'en fait la personne avec qui
tu parles rien de pompey a ce côté et
qu'en fait du coup de tête est en
décalage permanent là il ya plus
décalage donc non je me sens
je me sens en phase avec les gens et ça
c'est super cool et du coup de plus en
plus en phase avec moi-même et il ya le
la représentation médiatique parce que
ma forcément maintenant on m'appelle on
m'appelle pour parler de ce sujet alors
je suis pas du tout légitime que
quelqu'un d'autre si quelqu'un se sent
plus légitime que moi plus documentée
parce que moi par exemple je n'ai pas
subi de 20 je crois pas alors je n'ai
pas subi d'opération génitales infantile
que beaucoup de personnes inter
subissent
donc si anne barzin qui sent plus
légitime que moi qu'il est qui et vas-y
c'est juste qu'on m'appelle vont venir
et et ôter une voiture prend la place de
personne à la limite tu ouvre la voie
pour le bien sûr
il n'y a pas de soucis plus on en parle
pour moi mieux c'est je prédis en
conquérir à le mot non c'est juste ah
oui parce que j'entends ça seulement
aussi ouais vous voulez que tout le
monde soit soit comme soit comme vous
citer parce que je pensais prendre
souvent l'exemple des roues parce
qu'apparemment il ya autant de roues que
des codes intersexe on estime que les
personnes rousse comme les personnes
intersexe représente 1,7 pour cent de la
population mondiale
cité en rouge d'ailleurs alors dès que
tu as envie de parler de l'irlande et de
la rousseur tu vas y a personne qui va
te dire tu as envie que tout le monde
soit rond non on ajoute écouter et tu
vas tu vas vite parler de tout acte de
ce que c'est d'être où tu vois donc
pourquoi ça serait différent pour moi
moi j'ai pas envie que les personnes
deviennent deviennent interdits les
personnels doivent juste devenir selon
moi
ce qu'elles veulent devenir pour être
bien avec soi et avec les autres et le
monde qui les entoure ses plus jeunes
joueurs et espagne au rang des sujets
donc tu as dit t'as 29 ans tu as fait
tout un parcours tu as évolué dans ta
façon de de considérer etc
la cites avait un conseil à donner à une
personne intersexe qui est peut-être le
début de son sa vie de son adolescence
le début de son parcours un conseil à
donner à cette personne là aujourd'hui
ce serait quoi de se dire qu'on a qu'une
vie peu importe qu on croire la vie
après la main ou actuellement tu as un
corps tu as une vie
tu vas pour les autres les autres rives
ils vont pas changer pour toi et s'il ya
des gens qui acceptent pas ce que tu ais
je pense que
juste pas de place à avoir dans ta mixer
c'est très triste parce que
comment dire on pense aux déceptions
amoureuses c'est cette structure super
violence que que tu que tu as quand tard
quand as tu avais des rêves avec
quelqu'un et que et que ça ça tombe ça
peut aussi arriver dans la famille ça
peut aussi arriver dans l'amitié dès que
tu dis que tu met de l'espoir en
quelqu'un tu peux être déçu ça c'est
normal mais en fait si la personne elle
n'accepte pas
c'est juste qu'elle qu'elle méritait pas
d'avoir
d'avoir une place dans ta vie quoi tout
simplement donc je donc donc jeu
on dit on dit toujours on sait ce qu'on
perd on sait pas ce qu'on trouve en
général quand on perd quelque chose on
se dit qu'on va trouver quelque chose de
plus positif ça que ça que veut dire
cette expression la lan sens inverse on
va dire que ça veut dire que tu sais que
tu perds quelqu'un qui nous devons prier
donc côté personnes se retrouvent
d'autres gens
non seulement ça sera forcément mieux et
spoiler tu trouveras des gens mieux
c'est normal si toi déjà tu acceptes
contre accepte pas tu peux pas accepter
je dirais aussi à cette personne qui est
qui et intersexe que c'est pas une
obligation non plus de rester intersexe
si on impose des traitements on impose
des opérations aux enfants ados
intersexe mais effectivement si tu es
une femme que tu te sens femme ultra
féminine que tu vas voir des guides des
saints comme ça des anges comme ça et
tout et que et qu'on dit et intersexe
ben t'as tout à fait le droit la
question juste c'est qu'est ce que toi
tu as envie
profondément ya pas qu est-ce que qu'est
ce qui est plus simple
la bonne solution n'est pas forcément
plus simple mais à la fin elle est plus
satisfaisante merci beaucoup clément
merci julien et puis bientôt elle va
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]